Speaker 1: We have a good court decision to
tell you today regarding the pandemic and
guidelines.
There is a Dallas County judge that has ruled
against Texas Governor Greg Abbott's move
to ban mask mandates in the state.
Now, you if you're watching from another country,
for example, and you're in a country that
makes a little more sense than the United
States, thanks to the Republican Party, you
might assume if governors are going to get
involved with mask mandates, you would think
governors would say, hey, I'm not leaving
it up to the to the local level.
All schools must have a mask requirement in
place for the time being, for the upcoming
fall semester in order to prevent the spread.
But you would be wrong.
The involvement of governors in mask mandates,
particularly in red states, places like Florida,
Florida is a very 50/50 state.
But with Ron DeSantis, the Republican governor
of Texas, with Greg Abbott, the involvement
of governors has been to ban mask mandates
or at least to try to to ban vaccine requirements
or at least to try to add a Dallas County
judge says, no, you can't enforce it, you
can't do it.
You can't ban mask mandates if that is what
municipalities or schools or whoever wants
to do.
Judge Tanya Parker sided with Dallas County
Judge Clay Jenkins on Wednesday, issuing a
temporary injunction against Abbott's ban
on mask mandates.
The move will allow Jenkins mask order in
addition to similar policies in other local
school districts to remain in place for the
time being, Jenkins will now have the ability
to issue penalties to individuals who don't
comply with the county's policy, which requires
that masks are worn in businesses, schools
and county owned buildings.
Parker wrote in the ruling that Jenkins proved
that Dallas County residents, quote, will
suffer probable, imminent and irreparable
injury through county Judge Jenkins being
precluded from exercising his authority to
mandate masks in public.
So what the decision is and sometimes it's
like was that was something banned or was
the ban banned or did they ban bans on banned?
OK, you get the decision here is the governor
can't ban mask requirements as a as an umbrella
decision or direction.
The controversy in Dallas began when Commissioner
JJ Coke filed a lawsuit against Jenkins earlier
this month after being removed from a courtroom
for refusing to wear a mask.
Jenkins responded by filing a lawsuit against
Abbott over an executive order he signed that
banned mask mandates.
If you think this is the end of the road for
this, it is not.
The temporary injunction will likely be appealed
to the 5th Court of Appeals in Dallas and
then to the Supreme Texas Supreme Court before
a final ruling is made, Abbott's office said
in a statement.
It believes in the state attorney general's
ability to defend the executive order.
Imagine for a moment not only the money that
could be saved, but potentially the number
of infections that could be prevented, hospitalizations
that could be prevented, and some number of
deaths that could be prevented if instead
of focusing on banning public safety guidelines.
Instead, the Texas governor and his office
focused on encouraging vaccination, encouraging
safety protocol and working to actually get
beyond the pandemic, rather than these pathetic
shows about liberty and freedom and whatever
else.
But unfortunately, like we see it as not only
a waste of time, but as something that's bad
for public health.
The Republican Party, particularly in these
red states, is about obstructing, bringing
down anything on anyone who is trying to make
a positive impact under the guise of so-called
freedom and liberty.
And unless they start losing, they are probably
going to continue doing this for a long time,
because, as I've said before, they've completely
abandoned policy.
And if you think this is the only thing that
Greg.
Abbott is doing no yesterday, actually, executive
order, Geet 39, this is a vaccine mandate
ban, and the idea here is to prohibit vaccine
mandates and vaccine passports subject to
legislative action.
So while this is getting struck down, he's
trying to prevent vaccine mandates and vaccine
requirements and they claim to be about liberty,
freedom and not regulating business.
But yet they're going out of their way to
say we need the government to ban a private
business from making whatever decision is
right for them.
Normally, these are the people who say if
something is the right decision for a business
or even if it's the wrong decision, but they
think it's the right decision, they should
be free to make that mistake or to take the
correct action, except when they want to say,
hey, you know what?
It would be really bad for our business, for
unvaccinated people to come in and start spreading
the virus.
So we're going to require vaccine proof of
vaccination.
Oh, no, no, no.
Now, we need the full power of government
to regulate these people.
Not surprising.
They've been hypocrites for a very, very long
time.
And hopefully, I mean, we're we're sort of
in a race here not only against the virus,
but we're in a legis in a judicial race of
sorts, where we're constantly needing courts
to weigh in and to prevent destructive actions,
often self-destructive actions.
And if you want to take a look at where Texas
may be heading, just look at the covid health
scape that is Florida.
Look at Mississippi, look at Alabama.
Texas benefits from the fact that their health
care infrastructure is better than Mississippi
and Alabama.
Mississippi and Alabama are absolutely the
worst.
And look at what's happening in their economies.
But it is hitting Texas as well.
As I covered yesterday, three independent
emergency rooms in Texas have had to close
because the organization that runs them needed
to take all of their staff and bring them
to other facilities overloaded with covid.
So, as we've said before, if you get into
a car accident in Texas, you're vaccinated.
You have a health issue.
It's not even covid related.
You get into a car accident.
There are now three hours, which simply will
not be available because all of the staff
needed to be brought elsewhere to deal with
covid overwhelmingly in hospitalized unvaccinated
patients.
And this is going to continue.
We'll take a quick break after the break.
I do want to talk about a bunch of you sent
me these clips from an anti vaccine rally
in New York City.
It's scary.
You know, it's entertaining and it's cartoonish,
but it's also really, really scary.
We'll take a look at those videos right after
this short break.